yes a challenging you pigeon hearted
pusillanimous weasel academic weasel
fraud so I've always wanted to reply to
this video this video that ben shapiro
he put forward this video where he is
talking about islam and muslims and he's
trying to represent muslims in a certain
way he hastily generalizes in a really
unacquainted are with this kind of hasty
generalization but before we do so let's
take a look at actually some of the
claims that he's making first of all as
we can see in this video he speaks about
the Old Testament and the New Testament
and when he speaks about people who
believe in these things he acknowledges
that there are violent passages he says
in those books why he says there's
plenty of violent material in the Old
and New Testaments hey I'm an Orthodox
Jew I read the Old Testament a lot but
believers in those particular texts are
not currently ramming airliners into
towers or beheading journalists or
mutilating female genitalia
so why mention these examples is it
because you're trying to otherwise or
associate Muslims with particular acts
it's clear here that those three
examples are carefully chosen by
yourself and actually funny enough nor
even generalizable to Muslims let's take
your third example for example you talk
about female genital mutilation well
there is no evidence whatsoever that
most only Muslim countries practice this
act for example with the OPA is East
Africa many of those populations are
majority Christian populations yet the
act is very much or the practice of
female genital mutilation is very much
rampant in fact one of the books I've
written called fifth wave feminism I
dedicate an entire chapter on these
kinds of Acts our practices and how
they're committed in in the Western
world like for example if you look at
the WH old definition of what is in fact
considered female genital mutilation it
would be things like a labiaplasty why
is that not concerned and by the way
labiaplasty and clitoridectomy z' these
kinds of things are done right here in
the West and they're done at an alarming
rate more so than
any other place in the world so why is
that not referred to as female genital
mutilation and has that got anything to
do with Muslims no it's got nothing to
do with Muslims even that pacings pacing
of vagina is referred to as a kind of
mutilation by the w-h-o standard if we
take once again that measure what would
we say that that happens more in the
West or does that happen more in these
so once again I think you're trying to
create an image you're trying to create
a picture of a peculiar Muslim right and
it's a very failed image because when we
fact check some of the stuff that you're
saying quickly right as we're gonna find
out when we go through this one by one
bit by bit piece by piece then
everything like a stack of cards breaks
down in front of your very face let's
take a look at the next thing that you
say so you say that and this is so
important because you run with this okay
and in fact I would go as far as to say
is the majority of your video is based
on this faulty and unrecognized
definition which you don't even do a
good job in defining radical beliefs are
a lot broader than terrorists and
anybody who argues otherwise is being
naive or foolish or disingenuous but
defining what radical beliefs are not is
not defining what they are so by saying
radical beliefs are much wider than
terrorism what you're free to do as
we're gonna see in this video is
basically define a multiplicity of
things all radical beliefs but why
should we accept your chosen definition
in fact in the literature in the
political science literature when we
read the works of action or Pape or sage
men or any other they don't agree with
you in terms of that definition when we
talk about the process of radicalization
we're not talking about someone who for
example is we're gonna come to see with
your with your kind of pseudo
definitions that believes in or an acts
kind of Sharia law who agrees with this
definition it's not something which is
unanimous in the literature by any means
so you start with this faulty definition
and then you proceed in a way which
builds your faulty castle or your
Gosselaar on a thin air you building an
argument on a faulty premise and that's
what we're gonna expose today Indonesia
is the world's most populous Muslim
country it's got almost 205 million
Muslims living there and 70 percent
blamed the United States Israel or
somebody else for 9/11 so you make that
calculation it's about 143 million
people who are radicalized you scared
yet you know we're just getting started
so if it's true that someone who blames
the u.s. Israel or someone else for 9/11
is a radical as you're alluding to here
or you're kind to trying to suggest here
then all of those families who are whose
family member was killed on 9/11 who are
part of the truth movements in the
United States and all those kind of
things are you willing to come out and
say that they're radicals as well well
in fact you'd have to do that come out
and say that they are radicals those
people in America part of the truth
movements that they're all radicals if
that's what your definition entails
Bangladesh another 82% want Sharia to be
the official law of the country hey
Egypt 80 million Muslims according to
that same 2009 poll it showed that 65%
were on strict Sharia law in every
Islamic country the second aspects
strict support for Sharia law so I want
to know what exactly about Sharia law do
you think make someone a radical because
if you're saying Sharia law makes
someone a radical what exactly now I am
gonna assume that you're gonna say the
punitive laws because that's the most
controversial aspect of Sharia law now I
want you to answer me a question if
people believe the punitive and penal
laws of Islam and that makes them a
radical then what you say of Orthodox
Jews who read Exodus chapter 20 who read
Leviticus chapter 20 who read first
Samuels 15/3 and you can check those
references in your own time in The Book
of Numbers chapter 30 verse 8 check him
to check those number those reference
Gionta what about those individuals who
believe in those things they believe in
the capital punishment for murder for
adultery for in fact let me tell you Ben
let me tell you something Ben let me
tell you something Ben listen to me a
look at me
I am willing to say that all of the
punitive laws that are mentioned
classically in the text the primary text
of Islam and subsequently mentioned by
medieval scholars for example in
classical Jews potential texts they also
mentioned more severely yes more
severely in the halacha
texts of the Jewish Orthodox Jews so can
you now say that they are radicals all
of those Orthodox Jews who believe word
for word letter for letter the the
biblical discourse as it relates to
Penal goes you would probably come back
and say what hold on that's why it says
in the book but in terms of
implementation there's a difference and
we say the same thing we're not going
around saying well let's go cut
everyone's hands off and go and do these
things which are penal laws these things
as we know have a complex discussion or
how they are implemented but in the
modern world we're not saying let's go
and do a killing spree or do a murder
this and capital punishments know where
there's a complex discussion Muslim
scholars are having it just like Jewish
scholars are having it and there's a
spectrum of different opinion how
implementation can be done if it is at
all done in Muslim lands so if this
makes Muslims radicals and surely it
should be able to make Orthodox Jews
radicals as well because I say this
again almost all of the punitive laws
almost all of the penal laws are
iterated in the Old Testament almost all
of in fact more of them are there more
of their mother so that's what you tried
to skip in the beginning of the video
didn't you try to weasel from that one
try to scramble from that one try to
squirm from that one try to run away
from that one oh this violent passages
in the Old Testament do you not think
that some of these individuals who
believe in those violent passages maybe
could have a propensity to be inspired
as they were historically
contemporaneously to do any acts of
violence like the Ergun who killed 91
individuals innocent individuals in the
kingdom Solomon hotel who were a Jewish
terrorist group yes who then became
basically the guy
for intents and purposes the Luke it
party is now an extension from this
terrorist organization now you keep
mentioning who sama bin Laden in your in
your in your video and almost seventy
percent said that they had positive or
mixed feelings about bin Laden I imagine
begin who was who wrote this book called
the revolt he himself became the Prime
Minister of Israel now if that is the
case now you imagine after Osama bin
Laden has committed all of his attacks
he becomes the prime minister of some
country and he has an allied
relationship with the West so don't
don't please don't throw stones when you
live in the Glass House do you not know
your history and you not know your
religious book you claim you're an
Orthodox Jew but what exactly are you
advocating in terms of belief Nigeria
seventy five point seven million Muslims
live there 71% favor Sharia law that's
fifty three point seven million people
Iran seventy four point eight million
Muslims eighty three percent favor
implementation of Sharia law as of last
year so this is what he doesn't throw
the video he looks at all the countries
that believe in a strict go the majority
population believing the strict
compliance to Sharia law and he labels
them as radical but of course he
wouldn't have the same attitude to
Orthodox Jews who believe in very
similar things so I want to know first
of all who peer reviewed your definition
of radicalism who peer reviewed it
because when I was looking in the
academic literature I didn't find your
pseudo definition of radicalism it
doesn't actually exist number two why
are you not applying the same standards
on the Orthodox Jewish community if
that's what radicalism entails so it
seems like your presupposition is a
false one and therefore your
understanding is a problematic one
Bangladesh and two thirds said honor
killings of women can sometimes be
justified honor killings I looked at Pew
Research to see exactly what they're
talking about and what in fact they're
talking about in fact let me give you an
example
Indonesia says males it has Iran
achilles honor killing section talks
about the capital punishment for a
certain crime it says males for example
eight
2% believed that they would be eligible
for honor killings and also 82% of
female so it's exactly the same it's not
a female specific issue you're saying
they believe in female honor killings
but if you look at the biggest
population of Muslims in the world
Indonesia as an example but many of them
are the same those who believe in such
capital punishments usually believe in
it for both sexes now what are we
talking about when they say this are
they're talking about something which is
judicial it's a capital punishment for a
certain certain kind of crime or are we
talking about vigilantism oh and these
are very important you want says you
can't just skip by themselves they
believe in honor killings for women but
do they believe in I mean look at
Indonesia I believe 82% of them but even
honor killing for so-called Allah caliph
over but also for men so what are
they're talking about when they say this
and do they all mean the same thing when
they say these things these are nuances
which are very important so there's a
book called what a billion Muslims think
okay and there's a survey of 50,000
people Muslim people across I don't know
how many countries John Esposito and
Allium or more ga'head were part of this
this project and when we look at the
amount of Muslims who actually believe
in terrorism and killing innocent people
and civilians and stuff you will find
this a marginal number if you look at
page 97 to 98 of the book in the high
90s of people then the percentage of
high 90% believe that that is a
despicable crime and horrendous and so
on and so forth now we know you have to
remember something the Muslim
communities like 1.8 billion now in 2020
the Jewish community is not even 1% of
that so it's not like for like I'm
afraid if even 1% of the Muslim
community becomes radicalized in a
properly definitional sense in a violent
sense it will have massive ramifications
it's true and we do have a problem to
deal with we're not denying this as the
Muslim community we have to talk about
these things about the tech feeding
movements about those radical movements
about those repugnant movement the
monstrous crimes that they commit and
how to theologically remedy what they're
doing politically remedy what they're
doing and ideologically remedy what
they're doing but it's not fair for
someone like you to come up and
misrepresent an entire
people religious community by hastily
generalizing and giving false
definitions and not applying the same
standards of radicalization to one group
of people rather than others I want to
tell you something yes I've got
something in my hand this is an
unpublished paper that I wrote back in
2014 when I was doing one of my post
graduates in fact I was in the Leo Beck
Institute which is a situation such as
you probably more you should know let me
tell you something I was doing work to
see the extent of Jewish racism and in
fact I might publish this because when I
went on the Peace Index website it seems
to me that they're not working anymore
but this was one of the most robust
organizations that are teaming up with
Tel Aviv University
I remember referencing them now in this
and I was looking at the extent of the
problem of racism in the Jewish
community not look at this I want to
show you something yes I want you to
know something look at the amount of
racism you have in in the in the Jewish
come in the Israeli Jewish community
according to Peace Index survey
conducted in 2012 some sixty five point
two percent of Israeli Jews were either
moderately or greatly disturbed that
they were there were foreign workers who
came from countries like Sudan and
Eritrea so we're talking about greatly
40.5% that they had foreign neighbors
who came from Eritrea Sudan and Eritrea
in particular three black countries as
you know now I've never seen you come
out and talk about the clear racism in
Israel all we've do all we've seen with
you is you attacking the black rights
movement all but all black rights matter
movement but we don't haven't seen from
your attack any Jewish anti black
sentiments which we can see here with
this survey data or the survey data is
quite rampant same likewise as we know
with your own comment your anti-arab
comment when you're saying that Jews
like to build things and Arabs like to
bomb crap or something like this when
you learn and
Neels show 50% of Jews would not live in
the same building as Arabs and the
number fifty percent said they would
they would encourage their Arab
neighbors to emigrate to another land
what kind of numbers are these what kind
of things are these well I don't see is
that radicalism I won't ask a question
actually is that racism is can we say
that the majority based on the states
are here which conveniently the website
has sought it's not working right now
the Peace Index website because people
are using it like me to prove certain
things or to make sound claims but can I
say I've got this don't worry so but
it's all I have all I've taken
screenshots and I'm gonna show it to you
right now but when I say when I say this
can we say can we generalize the the
Jewish community in Israel Iser a racist
community by large and if this is
something we can say why don't you start
doing work against this using your
platform using your social media
influence instead of continually
attacking black people black people
black people or but the Blackfriars way
you don't want to admit even that the
guy who killed George Floyd was doing so
for racial reasons and you are at one
point hesitant on the fact that I should
he be
should he be prosecuted or not for
murder you were questioning this at one
point I'm not sure if you've changed
your mind
but do you I want ask a genuine question
I mean are you affected by this kind of
thing because you're yourself came up
with racist rhetoric so why not be open
and honest if we're going to be academic
about these things and we're going to be
open and honest yes we have a problem
with in Muslim communities but not all
Muslim communities are the same we're
talking about like you said 50 countries
with Muslim majority populations we're
talking about according to Pew that you
like to read to quote a religious
population that in the end of the
century will amount to one third of the
world's population and you want to
generalize those that's one third one
out of every three you can't even
compare them with Jewish people they're
like what thirty million people
worldwide there's more people in Morocco
than there are Jews in the world
so I mean please please be fair so the
reason why you only want to deal with
college students young ones untrained
ones little ones
weak ones in uneven situations and
settings is because your apostle animus
what did you say says you're a
pusillanimous timorous pusillanimous
ultra krappa Darien dilettante and you
don't want to face someone who can put
you in your place
yes I challenge you you pigeon hearted
pusillanimous weasel academic weasel
fraud you're a fraud you're a fraud and
I put you in your place I know you think
damn this guy's I was hoping I'll get
away with it if it wasn't for those
meddling kids you know what you're
finished finished you're finished you're
finished and you wouldn't come in death
even be in the same proximity as me and
I know you know that and that's all I
have to say on the matter
Salam aleikum wa rahmatullah hear what I
get
now having now that we've dealt with
this of the pusillanimous kind a
challenge you to a discussion on those
matters you see even though even this I
challenge the pusillanimous yes I
challenge you you pusillanimous
I know you're shivering
pigeon hearted pusillanimous of the
third degree
you